5 24 on your Wednesday morning what's  driving you crazy well we've got a  frequent viewer email complaint  returning with an unfortunate answer  Iris writes  on the 95 Northbound from Rancho to Ann  Road the carpool lanes full of single  drivers speeding past the afternoon  traffic what are they going to get nhp  out there to give these folks tickets  for one driving alone on a carpool lane  and two speeding doesn't make sense to  have a carpool lane if no one adheres to  the law  well Iris as we are still reporting  today there are real staffing issues  with the Nevada State Police Highway  Patrol member union representative  telling us a normal shift has upwards of  14 troopers on the road and that this  past Saturday they had only four for the  record no one here is suggesting drivers  disobey the law thanks for taking the  time to ride in buckle up drive  carefully please put down that phone you  can join the driving you crazy  conversation at traffic 8 at  8newsnow.com